foreign
[Music]
can I come to your house tonight
I don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography in a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
just the best day ever it is the best
day ever and so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and every day from now until
forever
you guys ever think about dying
when my heart breaks some things have
been happening that might be related
cold shower falling off my roof
And my heels are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what do I have to do you have to
go to the real world
and go back to your regular life or you
can know the truth about the universe
Choice isn't
the first one the high heel you have to
want to know okay do it again
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm coming with you okay
[Music]
wow this is the real world what's going
on why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Applause]
[Music]
real world that's impossible if this got
out this could mean extremely weird
things for our world
catastrophic
we haven't played with Barbie since we
were like five years oh
no one rests until this doll is back in
a box
[Music]
humans only have one ending get that
Barbie
[Music]
tears live forever
no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor I need a clicky pen
No a sharp thing no there he is Doctor
somebody get security
[Music]
is Bobby if you're still in doubt